you said you typically were more liberal
leaning now a little bit more
conservative my entire family I mean I
was raised in a democratic family yeah
sure that's just Hollywood some people
are you know raised yeah you know and
conservative families that grow up
Republicans some people are raised as
Democrats okay when you're a little kid
you're going up on your family okay I
went to a school that you know was very
conservative so I was like a minority
for having a family that was Democrats
right so like when you're a little kid
when you're in the fifth grade you know
what I'm saying when like you know Bush
was getting elected or some something
and you know you have your your little
school has like the elections right who
are the little who's a fifth grader
voting for they're just voting for the
president that their parents are voting
for right so they don't have any opinion
on politics they're just raised a
certain a certain way right so I was
definitely raised uh in that you know on
the left in the liberal Democratic
um you know just mindset culture
whatever but I truly consider myself a
complete modern turret complete moderate
I mean I I I truly believe that honestly
a two-party system is ridiculous because
what we're having to accept now is you
either have to it's it's a it's a it's
by you know bipartisan extremes right if
you have to accept the extremes of each
of each party
even though the like the most rational
you know decision or point of view is
always going to be more in the middle do
you know what I'm saying so it's like if
you you have to you're forced to like
pick a side
and then cosine even the most extreme
ideologies of that side
just because it's just because you're
picking the lesser of two evils but but
I honestly think that nowadays I mean
the the Republican party is a lot more
moderate than the Democratic party yeah
well they're both sides are extreme
whether you're talking about the woke
left or the absolute complete right
conspiracy right there is Maga right
right but that's moderate I think
moderate is great I'm I'm definitely in
that camp unfortunately if you're a
politician moderates don't get eyeballs
we're not eyeball culture yeah but I
feel like most people are truly moderate
you know like most people you come
across are are moderate you know what
I'm saying because it's like
like like I'll speak for myself for
example okay like I believe in the the
Second Amendment okay so that's like a
like a right ideology I also believe
that women should be able to get
abortions okay that's a left ideology
okay two completely rational things that
should be like com you know like logical
but people are forced to either go out
pick one side yeah and then accept all
the stuff that comes with it so if I
want to keep my guns now I gotta be now
I gotta be be rallying against abortions
you know what I'm saying because life
isn't black and white it's not life
isn't there's a gray area there's a
Nuance it could be liberal in some stuff
you could be conservative and others
exactly so I think that's the problem in
America today is that you're on team
blue or you're on team red yeah what
happened to red white and blue baby yeah
exactly like that's the problem in the
culture let me ask you one more
follow-up question since there seems to
be a moderate person who is more left
now you're more right there must be
things that upset you or trigger you
especially on the conspiracy side of
things like things aren't conspiracies
until they're actually proven true as an
example like freedom of speech they're
limiting our freedom of speech it's like
well they kind of are big Tech right of
course covet facts well yeah you can't
trust it it's like Well turns out you're
probably kind of couldn't right but then
you get into crazy conspiracy things
adrenochrome you know liberal Elites you
know blood babies that's where you lose
people and you're like that just doesn't
make any sense and then you hear stories
of like your father America's dad almost
you know drinking adrenochrome you've
heard these stories of course how do you
process that
I mean it's fanciful how do I process it
I think that I think that people are
crazy freaking you know sci-fi fantasies
are a lot more interesting as an
explanation for why things are the way
they are than real life or the real
answer there it's a lot more interesting
people are bored right people are bored
in their lives it's it's it's
interesting to get lost in these crazy
theories and conspiracies instead of
like looking at like you know the the
more simple probably more more truthful
answer of why things are the way that
they are so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]